ce qu'il nous faut c'est à tes
correctement les problèmes de la
pauvreté en France et il faut lutter
contre toute immigration nouvelle à 4
millions un peu plus 4 millions 200000
étrangers en France nous ne pouvons pas
héberger toute la misère du monde ce
n'est pas possible et pour ceux qui chez
nous vivent mal parce que leur quartier
sont dégradés parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
formation pas d'emploi pas de logement
qu'il soit français ou étrangers là et
la politique d'intégration de tous les
démunis de la société française c'est
pourquoi je pense que nous ne pouvons
pas héberger toute la misère du monde
que la France doit rester ce qu'elle est
une terre d'asile politique nous sommes
signataires de la Convention de Genève
qui prévoit de donner accueil à tous
ceux dont les libertés d'expression ou
dont les opinions sont réprimées sur
place mais pas plus